let's go out to harry reid airport i
imagine that those
thunderstorms affected air travel and
probably not in a positive way
yeah jerry take a look we're going to
show you the flights up on your screen
as you can see from delay to
cancellations according to the faa harry
reid international has been on a
thunderstorm ground departure delay
since noon at last check on
flightaware.com 45 flights have been
canceled and 249 have been delayed and
this isn't just a problem here in las
vegas you know several other airports
across the country are also seeing
delays and cancellations due to severe
weather i spoke to incoming travelers
today to see what their experience has
been
canceled didn't know it was canceled
till we got here got in line to check in
and they said it was canceled so
spending the night flying out tomorrow i
believe it's frustrating you know we're
having to take off another day of work
and for those of you dropping off
passengers be prepared for a potential
wait at the southwest airlines ticket
counter construction crews have begun
installing more steel post bollards in
front of the area causing some delays in
the last hour or so it has definitely
calmed down here with less people but we
will see if those cancellations or
delays increase within the next couple
hours coming up at 11 p.m reporting live
in harry reid international madison
kimbrough live local now